Speaker 1: Let's go next
to. Oh, I don't know, let's I'm told that
Tristin from Kansas City is back on Treston.
I hope your mikes work. Hey, there you are.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. So, as you know, I'm
a recovering, you know, not recover, but I used
to be a conspiracy theorist back in like 2016.
And of course, there's no shortage of conspiracy
theorists now. In fact, it's probably worse than
it's ever been. But there there is some videos
that I keep getting sent. And I'm wondering
if you know anything about the great reset,
because I would like a rational take on it,
because I saw the video by the World Economic
Forum and it is very dystopian, looking to say
the least. So do you know anything about that?
Speaker 1: I mean, correct me if I'm wrong.
The great reset is the idea that
on some kind of cyclical calendar,
there are events that sort of like call the week
and reduce the population and create kind of like
the idea of resetting and restarting more
strongly and that there's going to have to
be some bad things that happen. And so getting
to that point, including death and destruction,
but then you reset and then you build better in
a way. Is that generally the great reset idea?
Speaker 5: Yeah. And of course, everybody's
take that because it is you know, it's
it's a very challenging idea. And
of course, people are saying, oh,
that's the new world order that they're talking
about. And to quote one of the comments,
what I see it as a psychotic billionaire
is telling everyone how bad billionaires
are and they're the ones who are going to fix it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, here's the thing.
Every once in a while, this is the problem with
sophistry and pseudo intellectual ism that every
once in a while some idea that people who don't
read history or philosophy or political science or
whatever, they have no frame of reference. So they
hear like some hypotheses like this. And then all
of a sudden they're like, wow, this is the this is
like some grand theory that explains everything.
And they become very emotionally attached to
it. Whereas like a lot of people who do more
reading and studying would be like No. One thing
is the full explanation to everything. You know,
you read you have to read a lot of different
things. And there's aspects that make sense from
each thing. This is kind of like the problem with
pseudo an anti intellectualism that for people who
have no frame of reference, they hear one type of
idea one time and they become very attached to it
right away. And then you can't even have normal
conversations with them. So I don't know that I
have that much more to say about it other than
I don't think any one idea explains the world
in total. And we should be very skeptical of
anybody who points to this is the explanation
for why things are the way they are.
Speaker 5: Of course, yeah,
I think epistemology is the right word for it.
Speaker 1: Sure, yeah. I mean, understanding
where are why we believe the things we believe.
Speaker 5: Yeah, of course. All right. Well,
your comments section in this clip is probably
going to be pretty toxic. Just a fair warning, but
thank you, David.
Speaker 1: OK,
all right. Thanks very much. There's
Tristin from Kansas City, Missouri.